das böse kommt angeblich auf leisen
sohlen
doch plötzlich ist es da wir lügen
betrügen verletzten manche töten sogar
doch woher kommt das bösen schlummer das
in uns allen und warum fasziniert dass
uns so sehr
ja und über diese fragen diskutieren wir
gleich jetzt unter anderem mit einem
mörder der 25 jahre lang im gefängnis
gesessen hat und mit expertinnen und
experten die das böse tatsächlich zu
ihrem beruf gemacht haben
jetzt gleicht die sternstunde der nacht
im sog des bösen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alles begann mit einer sünde adam und
eva aßen vom verbotenen baum der
erkenntnis
schuld trägt die schlange die fortan das
böse verkörpert
zu unrecht wie wir mittlerweile wissen
wenn keine schlange ist zu verschlagen
hinterlistig und böse wie der mensch
stellt sich die frage woher kommt das
böse
wie nimmt es besitz von uns ist das böse
gewissermaßen schon in der natur
angelegt beispielsweise wenn leben oder
lebensräume zerstört werden oder kommt
es aufgrund eines göttlichen dualismus
zustande als thematischer gegenpol zum
guten steckt somit das böse in jedem von
uns ganz so wie es die legendäre
filmfigur hannibal lecter in das
schweigen der lämmer verkörpert und
welche faktoren müssen wirken bis das
böse die stufe des subjekts verlässt und
kollektiv wütet
fatal wie bei massen psychologischen
auswüchsen des dritten reichs der
harmlos obgleich durchaus
hinterfragenswert die lust am bösen in
kriminalromanen und tv-krimis wieso gibt
es so viele leute die sich blutrünstigen
geschichten freiwillig antun
die vielleicht banale antwort die welt
wäre möglicherweise um einiges ruhiger
gäbe es das böse nicht aber wohl auch um
ein vielfaches langweiliger und wer will
das schon
ja wer meint er gehört zu den ganz guten
wird jetzt gleich eines besseren belehrt
denen einer unserer heutigen gäste sagt
jeder kann zum mörder werden und das ist
lee diabetes ist eine gefragte
kriminalpsychologin als deutschland und
schreibt bestseller zu diesen themen zb
dieses hier auf dünnem eis die
psychologie des bösen zu gast ist heute
bei uns auch jörg noller er ist
philosoph philosoph an der lmu in
münchen
und er hat dieses buch hier geschrieben
theorien des bösen eine neue monographie
zum thema ist auf dem weg ganz herzlich
willkommen in beiden danke allah benecke
wir haben gesagt jeder kann zum mörder
werden auch ich das ist natürlich sehr
plakativ gesagt prinzipiell gibt es
menschen die von ihrer persönlichkeit er
mehr situative faktoren brauchen um so
eine tat zu begehen und anderen menschen
die eben schon in ihrer persönlichkeit
weniger hemmungen haben wenn sie jetzt
jemand sind der sagt ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass ich jemanden töten
könnte
dann ist die frage welche situative
faktoren müssten dazu kommen dass selbst
die das könnten es gibt ja beispiele wie
eben kriegsverbrechen wie zum beispiel
auch sehr schwere kriegsverbrechen wo
man nicht sagen kann dass jeder soldat
der daran beteiligt war für sich
genommen eine sehr schwer gestörte
persönlichkeit hat sondern hier spielen
dann sozialpsychologische faktoren eine
rolle
lassen sie uns doch zuerst mal noch über
wirklich die individuellen täter
sprechen mal jenseits noch des
konformismus und ich möchte trotzdem
nochmal wissen dass gesagt ich hätte
vielleicht so gewisse hemmungen aber
grundsätzlich kann das quasi jedem
passieren es gibt menschen die sind
näher dran und menschen die sind weiter
weg ist immer so meine faustregel
meisten menschen muss man in der
situation dazu kommen bei moment muss
nicht so viel in der situation dazu
kommen ich würde mich anschließen wird
aber noch hinzufügen dass es wesentlich
von unsere freiheit abhängt also wir
alle hier im raum sind frei und frei zu
sein bedeutet immer frei zum guten wie
auch zum bösen zu sein
natürlich tut man den seltensten fällen
das böse sehenden auges also ich sehe
das böse ich möchte es jetzt tun wir
belügen uns vielmehr und das kennt jeder
in kleinen ich will nicht sagen dass
jeder hier böse ist aber wann belügt
sich und das steigert sich dann immer
mehr und irgendwann ist man in so einem
gedankenkonstrukt dass er nicht mehr
rauskommt es gibt einige neuere
kriminalfilm um das genauer zeigen kann
auch über dieses thema der freiheit
wollen wir später noch sprechen wenn wir
jetzt mal die these noch stehen lassen
die alle haben irgendwie so böse
anteiligen drin
warum ist es denn so dass die
gefängnisse zu 90 prozent weltweit
gesehen von männern belegt sind haben
die männer mehr böses oder sind frauen
anders böse frau bin ich also da gibt es
verschiedene theorien und sehr
wahrscheinlich ist das nicht irgendwie
ein punkt der dazu führt sondern es gibt
wahrscheinlich ganz viele faktoren die
dazu beitragen da gibt es natürlich
einerseits hormonelle sachen klassiker
testosteron ist sexualhormon gibt
unendlich viele untersuchungen die
zeigen höhere testosteronwerte gehen
tendenziell mit einem aggressiveren
verhalten zusammen
männer haben logischerweise mehr
testosteron als frauen also wäre das
schon mal ein relativ offensichtlicher
punkt der dazu beiträgt dass männer mehr
zum beispiel gewaltakte als frauen
verüben aber es gibt auch soziale gründe
dass frauen zum beispiel auch andere
verhaltensstrategien lernen kulturell
und das habe ich auch in dem aktuellen
buch über psychopath innen beschrieben
dass da auch lerneffekt eine rolle
spielen ich sag immer sehr sehr sehr
vereinfacht wenn das der kleine junge
mitkriegt okay wenn ich irgendwie der
rowdy binnen der andere halt bedroht
dann krieg ich von denen das pausenbrot
und das kleine mädchen könnte lernen
wenn ich mich besonders niedlich
darstelle und zu anderen so ein bisschen
manipulativ bin vielleicht kriege ich
dann von denen die süßigkeiten sehr
vereinfacht das heißt es gibt auch
kulturelle lerneffekte ich würde es
ergänzend noch sagen wir sollten nicht
immer nur auf die taten des bösen achten
also auf der brutalen morde sondern auch
die geschichte die das böse hat das böse
entsteht ja nicht aus dem nichts das hat
mit langem vorlauf es schleicht sich ein
und es ist strategisch sehr sehr
geschickt das heißt für mich als
philosoph interessiere ich mich ihr für
diese vorlaufs geschichte und das sind
kleinere mechanismen die man bei männern
wie bei frauen denke ich passen einzige
vorlauf geschichte voraus geschichte
dass man sich in eine ideologie eine
fantasie
nein steigert dass man irgendwann da
nicht mehr raus kommt dass man sich
selbst über die interessen der
allgemeinheit setzt das man einem
nazismus verfällt das muss ich nicht
gleich einen konkreten brutalen
handlungen äußern das kann unmöglich
geschehen wird gern gleich am anfang von
ihnen auch noch hören warum sie
eigentlich das böse zum beruf gemacht
haben ich meinen sie beide befassen sich
ja eigentlich weiß nicht ob tag und
nacht aber zumindest am tag mit den
bösen herner was ist ihre motivation als
wir es oft genau dieses thema zu reden
also beruflich mache ich es nicht
beruflich bin ich eben philosoph und
maja theorien displays richtig ist eine
schattenseite unserer freiheit also ich
bin auf dieses thema durch meine
beschäftigung mit der menschlichen
freiheit gekommen und das böse so wie
ich es verstehe aus philosophischer
perspektive ist eine der seiten unsere
freiheit so wie wir das gute haben wir
uns zum guten entscheiden können aus
freiheit so eben auch zum bösen also
wird sagen die das böse ist die
schattenseite unsere freiheit und
deswegen muss man sich damit
notwendigerweise beschäftigen meine
philosophie ist oder philosophin ja ich
hatte einen biografischen weg der aber
vielleicht nicht unbedingt repräsentativ
ist für alle meine berufskollegen es
gibt ja sehr viele menschen die so wie
ich straftäter therapien und zum
beispiel psychologen sind und das so
machen sondern bei mir war es einfach
schon alles geht das interesse warum
menschen straftaten begehen und ich habe
dann immer schon kategorien angelegt
weil ich neige zum kategorisieren und
habe irgendwelche zeitungsartikel
gesammelt als kind und dann einfach
straftaten kategorien in ordner angelegt
wie andere leute mit briefmarken das ist
ein bisschen kurios ich weiß ist mir
bewusst jetzt so aber auf jeden fall
meine schule war sehr liberal was ich
wirklich sehr schätze sonst hätte das
vielleicht ganz anders eine kleine
schule so okay wenn das kind ein
interesse hat und die mutter hat nichts
dagegen dass sie mal machen
danke lieber schule und dann habe ich
das quasi deswegen später zum beruf
gemacht weil ich verstanden habe es ist
erklärbar es gibt in verschiedenen
kulturen in verschiedenen zeiten gibt es
ähnliche taten also muss es etwas sein
was auch wirklich tief im menschen drin
ist vielleicht ist da die überschneidung
zu dir das ist was sehr menschliche es
menschen gibt gibt es taten
und es gibt eine logik es ist nicht
komplett unverständlich sondern man kann
es rational erklären und das ist was
mich fasziniert sie sagen auch in ihrem
buch über sadisten was ich auch irgendwo
auf die sache
hier das lobbyisten buch da sagen sie
dass sie eine person sind die emotional
eher unbeteiligt bleibt ich glaube
solche brutale straftaten davon hören
die sagen wir sind leute sind
unterschiedlich gestrickt ja und ich bin
wahrscheinlich eher der andere typ das
alles belastet fände aber sie und das
war nicht echt interessant die sagen für
mich ist das einfach nur intellektuell
anregende wissen zusammengezuckt weil
ich überlegt habe wie werden eine welt
die in denen alle so unterwegs sind wie
sie ja nur intellektuelle getreten
es wäre das problematisch für sie das
ganze ich glaube dass es wichtig ist
dass alle eigenschaften die menschen
haben können dass die eben
unterschiedlich stark ausgeprägt sind
wir auf den lautstärkeregler es gibt die
leute die super emotionale gehen und die
leute die sehr sachlich sind und alles
dazwischen und es ist auch wichtig dass
es diese unterschied in der menschheit
gibt dann so gibt es halt für jeden
beruf und für jede sache die die
menschheit braucht quasi richtigen
ansprechpartner und spezialist darf ich
sie einfach noch fragen wie ist es bei
ihnen wie viel faszination ist auch
wirklich an richtig bösen gucken sie so
die richtig üblen horror findet nee nee
nee also mir genügt das in die
philosophiegeschichte zuschauen da finde
ich genug beispiele jetzt nicht an
grausamen morden aber an beschäftigung
mit diesem sehr komplexen phänomen uns
wurde schon gesagt das böse ist nichts
irrationales es erscheint so es erzeugt
den schein dass es dumpf und dunkel sei
aber wenn man genau hinschaut dann
produziert ist entscheidend ist täuscht
uns und das ist eine sehr spannende
geschichte und das kann man
philosophisch logisch versuchen zu
rekonstruieren zu verstehen verstehen
bedeutet jetzt aber nicht es gut finden
oder gutheißen sondern es
nachzuvollziehen wenn man schließlich
selbst auch irgendwie böse handeln
könnte
es betrifft also ein immer selbst auch
in der wurzel seiner eigenen existenz
was ich lerne ich schon ich habe hier
zwei sehr analytische und rational
denkende menschen vor mir vielleicht
hilft das auch bei der analyse des bösen
danke für diese erste einschätzung
wir gehen jetzt sehr nah an das böse
rahmen ich bin einer seltsamen situation
hier gegenüber sitzt jemand der satte 25
jahre im gefängnis gesessen hat unter
anderem wegen
die gurkhas hat eine richtig böse
vergangenheit kann man sagen ist
mittlerweile aber geläutert ist yoga
lehrer und gibt auch kurse für
schwerverbrecher er gurkhas vor 33
jahren sie waren damals 23 haben sie
eine frau getötet
warum haben sie das getan also im grunde
genommen kann ich es rein faktisch nicht
nicht sagen warum ich es getan habe
ich habe aus einem impuls heraus
gehandelt
aber letztendlich in der nachschau
meiner eigenen emotionen habe ich mich
damals glaube ich dazu entschlossen eine
unverzeihliche tat zu begehen und mir
selbst den rückweg in die gesellschaft
abzuschneiden
ich habe mich immer für sehr schwach
gehalten und um mich zu zwingen stark
sein zu müssen und den einmal
eingeschlagenen weg weiterzugehen bin
ich halt bereit gewesen auch über die
interessen anderer weit hinaus es gibt
eine lange vorgeschichte zu diesem raub
mord
also sie wollten schlichten kiosks haben
wir eigentlich wollte ich den supermarkt
überfallen aber das hat dann alles nicht
geklappt um ein komplize wollte und
nicht ohne geld wieder zurück nach hause
und dann haben wir uns entschlossen
irgendwann kleinen tante emma laden zu
überfallen und weil ich da eigentlich
nicht rein wollte habe ich ihnen dann
vorgeschickt und er ist die mysteriöse
völlig aus der hand gelaufen er wusste
nicht mehr was er tun sollte und da hat
das in meinem kopf klick gemacht und ich
hab halt so wie auf schienen
funktioniert und die ladenbesitzerin
umgebracht wie haben sie das gemacht ich
habe sie zuerst mit einem
schreckschussrevolver niedergeschlagen
und bin dann als ich die zweite person
die wir in dem laden gesehen hatten 500
zeit als sich die gesucht hat in einem
hinterraum wenn ich zurück gekommen und
bin hoch in die luft gesprungen und ihr
mit beiden füßen abgesprungen sie waren
ja die jahre davor muss man sagen bei
der polizei bekannt gesucht
sie waren drogensüchtig sie waren junkie
und gangster könnte man sagen in hamburg
wenn sie zurückdenken was ist für sie
der ursprung gewesen als sie auf diese
schiefe bahn gekommen
der ursprung liegt eigentlich wie glaube
ich bei allen menschen die sich dazu
entschließen in einen destruktiven
lebensweg einzuschlagen und damit meine
ich nicht nur verbrecher sondern sondern
auch die menschen die das legalisierte
böse betreiben die auf ihre eigene gier
hin arbeiten und so weiter das ist
letztendlich immer ein loch im
selbstbewusstsein dass menschen
er glaubt dass er so wie er ist von
seinem umfeld von seinem sozialen umfeld
nicht angenommen wird und versucht dann
sich besondere aufmerksamkeit zu
verschaffen sei es dadurch dass man viel
geld anhäuft oder eben halt sachen macht
die besondere aufmerksamkeit auf sich
ziehen
welche rolle haben ihre eltern gespielt
[Musik]
es würde jetzt verführerisch sein den
eltern die schuld zu geben aber ich
glaube dass straftaten immer die eigene
entscheidung sind und selbst in dieser
situation wo sie gesagt haben die
branche hat mich unter drogeneinfluss
ich ja das ist das nicht das ist zwar
frei ich habe ja irgendwann die
entscheidung getroffen drogen zu nehmen
und das hat dann dazu geführt dass ich
bereit war zustände zu akzeptieren in
denen solche kontrollverluste überhaupt
möglich sind
also ich bin ein vollkommener gegner des
absprechen des freien willens ich glaube
dass jeder mensch die entscheidung zur
destruktiven handlungen irgendwann
trifft
und dass er solange er nicht bereit ist
dafür die verantwortung zu übernehmen
auch diesen destruktive weg nicht
wirklich verlassen kann weil er seine
eigene entscheidung nicht akzeptiert er
sucht entschuldigung in dem verhalten
anderer solange wir das tun solange wenn
ich begreifen dass wir meister unseres
eigenen schicksals sind so lange sind
wir auch nicht wirklich bereit einen
positiven auf die liebe ausgelegten weg
also eigentlich sehr nahe am
existenzialismus die philosophische
position gesagt letztlich sind wir immer
radikal frei wir können uns immer
entscheiden das würden sie sagen lassen
sie uns über den gefängnisaufenthalt
sprechen sie wurden dann zu 13 jahren
haft verurteilt sind 1988 dann
ausgebrochen auch kam dann sechs jahre
knappe sechs jahre habe ich in
isolationshaft stimmt dass es insgesamt
habe ich mehr als sieben jahre in
isolationshaft gesessen
nach dem ausbruch gar nicht mal
besonders lange nur sieben monate aber
danach habe ich dann auch noch habe ich
daran beteiligt eine revolte im
gefängnis zu organisieren und das hat
mich dann für weitere vier jahre in
isolationshaft gebracht wie überlebt man
dass meine taktik war zu hassen
ich war zornig wut war meine war meine
kraftquelle und ich bin zornig gewesen
aber nicht eigentlich noch selbst doch
auch zorn steht immer selbst wenn man es
sich eingesteht und sich einredet dass
man wirklich innerlich noch so böse ist
entsteht der zorn diese ganz dieser
ganze diese ganze wut entsteht
letztendlich immer aus trauer oder angst
also wird es immer rechter der trauer
wenn ich zu traurig bin und die trauer
nicht aushalten kann werde ich wütend um
das zu bemänteln
und wenn ich angst habe verhalte ich
mich aggressiv um diese angst zu
übertünchen
und das sind die beiden grund merkmale
die ich bei tausenden von
strafgefangenen mit denen ich zusammen
gelebt habe ich habe das ja nicht nur
theoretisch aus irgendwelchen büchern
ich habe mir den menschen zusammen
gelebt und
letztendlich habe ich immer angst und
schmerz hinter all dem destruktiven
verhalten wovor haben sie angst
ich hatte angst sozial nicht anerkannt
zu sein nicht der science ich durfte
nicht der sein der ich wirklich war
ich war ein sehr sensibles weiches kind
ich bin sehr sehr empathisch das durfte
ich durch yoga dann später wieder
entdecken
aber das war eigentlich die seite an mir
dich am meisten verachtet habe weil ich
gelernt habe
indianer herz kennt keinen schmerz echte
jungen wein nicht und so weiter das ist
nicht böse gemeint gewesen von meinen
eltern das ist einfach in den späten
60ern ist dass das normale männerbild
gewesen und aber diese herde hat ihnen
danach geholfen im knast über die jahre
das haus zu halten
nein also dass das ich habe dann ja auch
noch zehn jahre im gefängnis gesessen
nachdem ich eine so spinner geworden bin
und total auf die liebe ausgerichtet war
und meine mitgefangenen überredet habe
yoga kurse zu besuchen und so und auch
die knast habe ich überlebt also das ist
ja nur wieder nur so eine schein
konstruktion die wir uns selbst
vormachen dass wir glauben hart sein zu
müssen um harte lebensbedingungen zu
überstehen
das gibt die geschichte von wild bill
das ist ein auschwitz insasse gewesen
der mit angesehen musste wie die ss
seine ganze seine frau und seine kinder
erschossen hat hat sie angefleht sie ihn
auch zu erschießen
ich habe es nicht getan weil er war
anwalt sprach mehrere sprachen die
konten zu gebrauchen
und dann hat er die ganze zeit in
auschwitz überlebt und ist als einer der
ganz wenigen ohne gewichtsverlust
entlassen worden obwohl er ständig sein
essen verschenkt hat und so weiter
das sind sachen die man eigentlich kaum
glauben kann die aber für mich belege
sind dass man wenn man sich der liebe an
sich übergibt das man dann ein relativ
gefühl
lebensweg gehen kann dann kam das bei
ihnen diese rolle die kam ja
verhältnismäßig spät
ja die kam sehr spät das war ja da waren
waren meine straftaten schon schon nahe
20 nahezu 20 jahre 1400 freigelassen
zwischendurch muss man sagen zwischen
und und dann wieder hin nur schlimmer
geworden
der ganze druck den das gefängnis auf
mich ausgeübt hat hat nur zu einer
weiteren inneren verhärtung geführt
hier ist als ich mich selbst mit mir
selbst beschäftigt habe und diesen
spiegel denen das leben und versucht
vorzuhalten nicht mehr ausweichen konnte
weil ich immer deutlicher mich selbst
gesehen habe da kam in mir irgendwann
der entschlossenheit
ich möchte nicht so sein ich möchte
eigentlich jemand ganz anders sein ich
möchte auf die liebe ausgerichtet sein
und dann habe ich das in mir gesucht und
auch gefunden weil das hat jeder mensch
bringt das mit genau so wie jeder mensch
das böse mit bringt das ist uns alles
vorhanden aber nicht jeder mensch tut
sowie sänger die sie getan haben wir
leben sie mit dieser schuld heute also
um mit schuld umzugehen ist es am besten
zu vergeben
sie können sich vorstellen dass nach 25
jahren haft es massenweise menschen in
meinem leben geht auf die ich genervt
sein könnte den ich böse absichten mir
gegenüber unterstellen könnte und so
weiter und so fort und mein umgang mit
der schuld war wirklich alle von denen
ich meinte dass sie mir etwas böses
angetan habe in meinem herzen das
allerbeste zu wünschen in wirklich alles
glück dieser welt zu wünschen und das
hat für mich dazu geführt dass diese
last der schuld immer geringer vor
denken inzwischen dass noch eine große
trauer über das leid dass ich anderen
menschen zugefügt habe aber diese große
last der schuld hat mich verlassen indem
ich vergeben haben sie heute noch angst
vor dem bösen das in ihnen schlummert
nein überhaupt nicht weil es ist immer
unsere entscheidung
sieben herzlichen dank für dieses offene
gespräch herr burkas wir werden sie
gleich noch mal hören zu ende spielen
darf
dies niemals gesagt die tat die ist
absolut frei würden sie das wirklich
genauso bestätigen
ja also was gerade gesagt wurde würde
ich total unterschreiben
es ist so dass es immer unsere
entscheidung ist zum bösen nur eben
nicht so dass wir das böse wirklich
sehenden auges wählen sondern da spielt
eine selbsttäuschung immer eine ganz
zentrale rolle
es wurde gesagt die angst ist am anfang
wir weichen vor der welt zurück wir
ziehen uns zurück und was machen wir in
dieser situation wir bauen und
konstruieren uns eine eigene welt eine
scheinwelt und in dieser scheinwelt
radikalisieren wir uns immer mehr ist
irgendwann unter bestimmten umständen
dann die böse handlung zustande kommt es
ist also im wechselspiel von freier
entscheidung und verstrickung in einem
system von lügen von schein aus dem wir
dann irgendwann auch nicht mehr
rauskommen und irgendwie unfrei werden
wir werden also unfrei aus freiheit zu
sagen aber sie frau wenige die erben jan
ihrer therapie die unterschiedlichsten
menschen vor sich und sie machen ja auch
eben immer noch so kategorien ich habe
neben dem buch geschrieben über sat ist
nein sie wird psychopathin ein anderes
über psychopathen glaube eher das heißt
es gibt ja schon auch krankheitsbilder
könnte man jetzt mal so sagen also
typologien von tätern und wenn sie auch
farben jeder von denen 13 also es gibt
ja täter typologien wobei natürlich
nicht jeder täter im klinischen sinne
psychisch krank ist sondern bei meisten
spielen die situative faktoren mehr eine
rolle und bei manchen vielleicht er
klinisch pathologische sehr häufig bei
schwereren straftaten kann eine rolle
spielen bestimmte persönlichkeit viele
oder persönlichkeitsstörungen dessen
fließender übergang in der psychologie
persönlichkeit viele haben viele
menschen das macht die individuelle
persönlichkeit aus das sind so die
gefühls gedanken und verhaltensmuster
die können natürlich in bestimmten
situationen begünstigen das mensch sich
so oder so entscheidet bei der störung
persönlichkeitsstörung sind die gefühle
gedanken und verhaltensmuster stereotype
als beim normalen menschen vielleicht
ein beispiel man kam nazis designer oder
kann der narzisstische störung genau
also jemand der jetzt wirklich eine
narzisstische persönlichkeitsstörung
hätte der hätte und doppelte selbstbild
zum beispiel rainer sachse ein
psychologe aus deutschland mal
so zusammengefasst dass die früher ein
sehr schlechtes selbstwertgefühl hatten
das ist ähnlich wie jetzt gerade in der
geschichte auch gehört und dass dann
überkompensieren mit dem bedürfnis
absolut unantastbar und mächtig zu sein
und eben niemand kann mehr an diese
person ran und dann sagt man dieser
mensch ist aber sehr narzisstisch
gekränkt war er kann sehr schnell in wut
geraten weil in dem moment wo er
angetippt wird mit selbstzweifeln ist
eben emotionale schmerzen erzeugen wut
erzeugen narzisstische kränkung und das
kann im schlimmsten fall zum beispiel zu
aggressionen führen in verschiedenen
bereichen
also es gibt von
persönlichkeitsstörungen die bei meisten
straftätern häufiger vorkommen zum
beispiel auch die antisoziale oder
dissoziale genannte
persönlichkeitsstörung wo menschen halt
sehr bedürfnisorientiert sind wenig
angst und wenig mitgefühl und
schuldgefühl haben und dadurch weniger
grenzen in ihrer persönlichkeit haben
als andere menschen sich einfach über
regeln hinwegzusetzen und über das wohl
anderer genau und ich dann die person
wirklich noch frei und das ist die große
frage zum beispiel wenn es um die
schuldfähigkeit geht dann wird häufig
diskutiert ob zum beispiel schwere
persönlichkeitsstörung mischungen ob die
schon sozusagen die willensfreiheit
dieses menschen in der tat situation
soweit beeinträchtigt haben dass er sich
in diesem moment nicht anders
entscheiden konnte wobei man meistens
sagt bei einer persönlichkeitsstörung
selbst wenn ein mensch sagen wir wenig
angst hat wenig mitgefühl schuldgefühlen
sehr bedürfnis orientieren ist wenn der
aber weiß ich darf jetzt nicht die bank
ausrauben okay das weiße rational und er
sagt ich will jetzt aber dieses geld
weil ich will jetzt meine bedürfnisse
befriedigen weil er spürt man diese
bedürfnisse hat keine angst keine
hemmung und er plant das holt sich eine
waffe geht in die bank dann hat er
vielleicht eine antisoziale
persönlichkeitsstörung möglicherweise
aber er weiß dass er das nicht darf er
handelt planvoll und zielgerichtet das
heißt er ist verantwortlich im
juristischen sinne und das würde ich
auch ethisch so sehen das heißt wir
sagen unseren klienten
persönlichkeitsstörungen leiden ja sie
haben aufgrund ihrer persönlichkeit es
vielleicht in manchen situationen leicht
dass sich um sozial zu falten aber sie
haben die wahl und da sind wir bei der
freiheit und sie wussten sie hätten sich
anders entscheiden können und deswegen
haben sie die verantwortung so ich
stimme ihm zu den bestimmen sie zu was
ist denn eigentlich genau
der böse oder das böse und ich frage
nochmal so präzise nach
weil zum beispiel ferdinand von schirach
ganz klar sagt es mag die böse tat geben
den bösen menschen den gibt es
eigentlich kaum jeder sind ganz ganz
wenige menschen von denen wir wirklich
sagen kann 'die sind böse sondern das
ist auch was anderes jahre haben böse
anteile und dann kann sich mal zu viel
werden und dann geschieht die böse tat
aber er schreckt davor zurück diese
wertung vorzunehmen
sie tun das scheinbar wenn ich jetzt so
den eindruck habe relativ unbefangen
nein da würde ich auch sagen wir müssen
aufpassen
über das böse so zu sprechen als ob es
das böse gebe oder die böse person den
bösen täter den bösen menschen
ich glaube wir sollten lieber böse klein
schreiben also vom das böse zum böse
kleingeschrieben adjektiv auf was trifft
dann das böse zu jetzt rede ich wieder
natürlich von erlösen aber was kann
alles böse sein ich vor allem sagen
handlungen gedanken sogar auch gedanken
konstrukte willens entscheidungen
willens maximen einstellungen gegenüber
der welt das sind die fälle die wir
lösungen und was macht die these dass
sich die qualifikation hört das böse
besteht darin dass darin ein falsches
selbst welt verhältnis zu grunde liegt
also das individuum im bau eine
scheinwelt auf radikalisiert sich in
dieser scheinwelt und immunisiert sich
auch gegenüber rat und hilfe von außen
es wird sozusagen es schaltet sich immer
mehr ab ok haben wir diese scheinwelt
mehrere male schon gehabt ich würde
gerne mal eine definition reinbringen
von marquis de staat der für den ist der
böse mensch ein zweck rationaler egoist
der weder solidarität noch mit gefühl
kennt und nur kooperiert wenn der eigene
vorteil daraus erwächst
das scheint mir jetzt eine relativ
plausible alltags definition zu sein
die frage ist ob es wirklich menschen
gibt die das hundertprozentig erfüllen
es gibt sich an menschen die da näher
dran sind als andere
und da muss man sich aber auch dann
fragen woher kommt denn diese
persönlichkeit mischung also diese
definition ist sehr nah dran an unserem
konstrukt der psychopathie menschen
wirklich wenig mitgefühl schuldgefühl
angst haben so wenig von denen grenzen
der normalen menschen und ganz viel
bedürfnis orientierung impulsivität
reizbarkeit also sie wollen ihre impulse
aus leben und sie haben wenig grenzen
sehr vereinfacht gesagt
und da könnte man natürlich sagen ja das
klingt ja wie ein böser mensch der viele
eigenschaften die nicht sehr sympathisch
machen der macht sein ding ist auf sich
fokussiert dann ist aber die frage woher
kommt das früher hat man gedacht es gibt
menschen die werden so geboren und
andere werden so gemacht
heute sagt man es ist immer eine
mischung aus beidem immer anlage und
umwelt
das heißt unter bestimmten
umweltfaktoren hätte sich diese
persönlichkeit nicht in dieser
extremität so geformt wie aber jetzt
soll bleibt denn ihr das hier die
freiheit ja genau und dann ist die frage
wo ist die freiheit und er an der stelle
sage ich mal gut dass ich kein philosoph
und kein jurist bin das gebe ich gerne
einen philosophen weiter wir hoffen ja
und noch einen weiteren grund anführen
warum wir menschen nicht als böse
grundsätzliche wesentlich bestimmen
sollten und zwar deswegen weil wir jede
menschen die freiheit zugestehen sollten
sich wieder zum guten zu entscheiden
auch wenn eine schreckliche tat
vollbracht wurde ist es doch prinzipiell
möglich da zitat zu bereuen und sich auf
einen guten weg zu begeben haben wir
jetzt ja auch gerade gehört und wenn wir
den menschen als wesentlich böse
definieren dann diskriminieren wir ihnen
dann stigmatisieren wir ihn und stempeln
ab dass er sich vielleicht gar nicht
mehr ändern könnte und das sollten wir
jeden menschen offen hat leuchtet mir
ein jetzt haben wir sozusagen das eine
extrem gesprochen nämlich darüber dass
man vielleicht gar nicht mehr über den
bösen menschen sprechen könnte darüber
dass es wirklich böse böse menschen gibt
es gibt ja auch die tendenz sozusagen
das böse oder das schlechte in der welt
auch zu katalogisieren und damit
eigentlich zum naturphänomen zu machen
also alles was passiert kann man sich
kausal erklären und eben auch die bösen
handlungen das sind halt einfach
naturereignisse und damit würde das
moralisch böse eben die böse tat auch
eigentlich verschwinden es gebe nur noch
die schlechte tat also wir waren mord
wäre dann so was in erdbeben da sagen
sie ja na das wäre eine katastrophe
philosophisch gesehen warum brauchen wir
denn dass diese wir würden dann menschen
die freiheit absprechen wir würden
menschen wie sie selbst sagten wie
naturkatastrophen wie natur defekte
behandeln wir würden sie für
objektivieren zu bloßen objekten
degradieren wir würden ihnen ihre
freiheit und ihre würde auch
letztendlich nicht
als individuum und darauf sollten wir
glaube ich nicht verzichten in die würde
also zuzusprechen
das hätte ein riesenproblem für die
anerkennung von personen wie ist das für
sie wenn die so einer person gegenüber
sitzen einer person jetzt eine straftat
begangen hat ja also ich hab auch in
meinem ersten buch mal geschrieben dass
ich halt auch er böse taten sehr als
böse menschen weil in den allermeisten
menschen sowohl gute als auch schlechte
anteile drin sind also das sehe ich
genauso
und selbst der mensch der sehr viele
dieser risiko eigenschaften in sich
vereint die ich gerade erwähnt habe von
solchen menschen gibt es aber auch
statistisch gesehen relativ wenige diaz
so extrem in sich haben selbst die haben
häufig noch irgendwelche positiven
anteile selbst wenn sie noch so klein
sind und die meisten menschen die sehr
schwere straftaten begehen sind aber gar
nicht so schwer in ihrer persönlichkeit
beeinträchtigt und da kann man
therapeutisch einiges machen zum
beispiel so tötungsdelikte einiges von
dem was wir gerade gehört haben kenne
ich auch aus therapien und ähnliche auch
beschreibungen der lebensläufe auch
dieses hart sein weil eben die
emotionalen anteile als schwäche erlebt
werden
das ist sehr interessant dass viele
derjenigen die dann später so eine
dissoziale entwicklung nehmen von denen
ich auch einige schon in behandlung
hatte dass die häufig sagen als kind war
ich eher der der sich schnell was zu
herzen nahmen der schnell verletzt war
ging aber nicht als junge die story muss
ich hart sein und dass einige wenn auch
nicht alle dann diese überkompensation
machen mit diesem mit diesem massiven
mauer drum rum ich bin jetzt der super
stark und unangreifbar und dann also
auch manchmal die soziale karrieren
entwickeln
ich sehe immer die gesamtgeschichte des
menschen und gucke okay kann man bei
diesem menschen jetzt noch die dinge
eben so verändern dass er einen anderen
lebensweg einschlagen kann mit anderen
entscheidungen und wir arbeiten viel mit
willensfreiheit in der therapie
ich habe menschen in therapie die sind
voll schuldfähig gewesen
das heißt sie wussten das ist falsch es
hätten sich anders entscheiden können
haben aber häufig schon persönlichkeit
auffälligkeiten die halt die
wahrscheinlichkeit erhöht haben dass sie
sich falsch entscheiden und wir sagen
der freie wille wird jetzt genutzt und
sie müssen lernen den zu nutzen um
risiken zu erkennen um andere
entscheidungen zu treffen und sie sind
verantwortlich mit ihrem freien willen
für die zukunft ihres lebens
und wenn ich jetzt mal ganz persönlich
frage so beneke gibt es nie die
situation dass sie da sitzen und dass
wir die niemand zugeteilt für die
therapie und sie denken das kann ich
jetzt wirklich nicht das geht mir
einfach zu weit was er gemacht hat hatte
ich noch nie so dass ich vermute sonst
hätte ich mir einen anderen job gesucht
ich habe viele menschen kennengelernt
ein praktikum gemacht haben zum beispiel
mit straftätern und einige sagen dann
sie haben diesen effekt dass sie sagen
das geht mir zu nah das ist mir zu krass
ich kann mit diesen menschen nicht
arbeiten ich habe vorbehalte ich habe
wut gegen den oder so und wenn sie das
halt nicht abstellen können dann können
sie diesen job halt nicht machen ich
hatte das tatsächlich noch nie weil ich
irgendwie zielorientiert und eben eher
analytisch rangehe und wohl dass der
grund ist warum es mir mit meiner arbeit
recht gut geht und ich denke die meisten
meiner kollegen die gehen auch
analytisch und rational ran sonst würden
die natürlich auch diesen job nicht
jahrelang machen können
ich würde gerne noch eine drehung machen
sie haben wunderbar erklärt warum sie
glauben wir müssen an das moralisch böse
glauben weil nur dann kriegen wir auch
die freiheit gerettet quasi aber
eigentlich hätten wir doch alle auch
gerne eine bessere welt wie können wir
denn auf die bessere welt hoffen wenn
wir gleichzeitig den gebrauch und das
böse
ich denke wir sollten gut und böse nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen diesem sinne
sondern wir sollten versuchen im bösen
schon etwas gutes angelegt sehen
das ist jetzt ein bisschen paradox
formuliert tatsächlich handeln das gute
im bösen sein wie wir früher schon ein
bisschen besprochen hatten es ist die
freiheit die freiheit zum guten wie zum
gewesen also im bösen liegt auch eine
art von energie die im positiven
eingesetzt werden kann somit triebkraft
und wenn wir diese triebkraft auf die
richtige bahn lenken
dann haben wir das gute im bösen zum
guten gewendet würde ich sagen also das
ist sollten wir glaube ich nicht
unterdrücken oder ganz ausklammern
sollten versuchen ist zu transformieren
zu gut sind jedoch nicht fast schon bei
nietzsche der tatsächlich meint er das
böse ist die eigentliche kraft ja gut im
bösen zeigen sich manche eigenschaften
einer besonderen perfektion die wir
manchmal beim guten nicht zu erkennen
glauben zum beispiel eine woche hoch
intelligente planung von taten ein
soziales konstrukt von fantasie
so was sieht man häufig im guten nicht
damit ist aber nicht gesagt dass das
böse jetzt gut ist aber sind eine
gewisse spuren und tendenzen enthalten
die wir auch in guten gebrauchtspiele da
so eine gewisse bewunderung auch haben
sie zum lieblingsplatz
es gibt da viele ich meine zum beispiel
jetzt der mephisto mephistopheles in
goethes faust oder auch den teufel in
paradise lost von john meltzer es gibt
viele klassische figuren des bösen jago
bei shakespeare solche figuren die sind
jetzt nicht dumm
die sind nicht dumm von diesen hoch
intelligent nur gebrauchen sie ihre
vernunft auf die falsche weiß als sie
sollten ihre intelligenz bewahren aber
fürs gute einsätzen hatten siemens und
lieblingsfach lieblings glaube ich echt
nicht so in meinem job ist klar dass
nicht weil was sollte das sein und
ehrlich gesagt sind ja alle fälle mit
denen ich arbeite schon auch grauen
freue ich finde das immer also
interessant in gruppentherapien ich habe
gruppentherapien für sexualstraftäter
und für gewaltstraftäter also sowohl für
menschen die sexualdelikte begehen also
für menschen die zum beispiel menschen
getötet haben auch und manchmal gibt es
dieses phänomen dass dann ein neuer
kommt und sagt ich bin gar nicht so
schlimm wie der da weil der hat
irgendwie eben mehr leute umgebracht
oder mehr leute vergewaltigt und dann
fangen die straftäter untereinander an
plötzlich das böse abzuwägen und dann
sagen wir so halt wir machen hier nicht
irgendwie ein abwägen wer hat jetzt mehr
kilo böse ist auch seiner waage
drauflegen sondern jeder von ihnen hat
opfer und familien von opfern und das
ist in jedem einzelfall hier einfach
grauenvoll eigentlich in den effekten
die das was sie getan haben hatte und
dementsprechend ist jeder von denen in
der verantwortung muss auch
schuldgefühle und mitgefühl durchaus
aktiviert bekommen das was dieses sich
schön reden ist das sind kognitive
verzerrung also manche menschen die
straftaten begehen und die eigentliche
gewissens instanz haben die reden sich
das schön die sagen zum beispiel der
oder die hat sich falsch verhalten oder
wäre mein leben nicht so ungerecht
gewesen dann hätte ich ja gar nicht auf
diese schiefe bahn abgleiten müssen da
gibt es ganz viele typische kognitive
verzerrung und die werden aufgedröselt
und bei denjenigen die eine gewissens
instanz haben und das sind die meisten
der täter kommt man dann wenn man diese
verzerrung auflöst in der therapie an
diese instanz an wo sie plötzlich
realisieren oh mein gott ich bin schuld
und dann wenn sie es nicht nur rational
verstehen sondern auch fühlen gibt so
einen emotionalen breakdown was im
idealfall sehr gut ist für eine therapie
verlauf dann haben sie jemanden der von
der persönlichkeitsstruktur durchaus so
was fühlen kann und das ist präventiv
sehr wichtig weil wenn einmal diese
ganzen nebel weg sind und sie wirklich
klar sehen und es auch fühlen dann ist
das schon präventiv sehr gut das ist
natürlich nur ein kleiner baustein von
ganz vielen weil therapien dauern jahre
aber trotzdem als beispiel
wir stehen schon wirklich am abgrund der
menschlichen psyche und brauchen eine
kurze pause die liefert uns jetzt
dominierte will der comedian und was
viele wahrscheinlich vielleicht nicht
wissen der nicht nur kinder gärtner war
sondern auch kindergärtler beides
miteinander darum geht es jetzt gleich
im ersten intermezzo
wir werden natürlich über das böse red
der rummel ist zudem fraglich denn die
böse anlage von der münchner ist es sind
böse böse oder entwickelt der
bösartigkeit dem umstand ihrer über 15
jahre mit ihm zusammen chance ein
ungetrübter unverblümt der blick auf das
rohmaterial das münchner der fans also
dass fünf bis sechs jahre sind eher gags
almeria sind beobachtet und ich schaue
jetzt ohne eine steuer- und ganz öffnung
mutig sagen so viel gewinnt ist bös und
hinterhältig das markt vista spezielle
sortieren und zu sagen
der minister sei noch nicht ziehen es
muss doch wunderbar sie wenn du am
morgen im hintergrund und flüssig und
die offsteiner mit stunts dankbare hinzu
nein so ist es nicht wichtig dass er
gewinnt ist nicht dankbar
sie ist es auch sehr gefehlt dieses
egoismus egozentrisch wasser und um es
sicher nur 116 auf mittelpunkt der erde
und die aufgabenfelder garten ist es das
kind der it geräte funktionieren die
gesellschaft das natürlich umso schwere
gerät wenn du deine version eine
gruppierung von münster andere
egoistische dozenten diversifiziere und
viel licht geht doch als beispiel wo
jeder für israel vor hinter heimat sich
noch nicht so lang harte muttertag wer
da etwas muttertagsgeschenk repro handel
es muss dann sagt sie und einige über
euro wäre hätten des muttertags geschenk
repro bundes das ganze acht und sind
ehrlich wo sich achtet das geschenk
freute die baustelle wo das geschenk
wird auch auf minister kim öffentlich
handel das ist krank aber wenn es nicht
vom eigentlichen david aufwand eine
ranke das regal losen stellen oder im
großen haus grabstelle minute frage wer
hätte doch richtig los stoffhaube
bastele wahrscheinlich die wenigsten
ja ist ja klar da davon so einfach und
es blickt sie papieren zusammen geflickt
und mit hoher farbe verschmiert
jetzt ist ja so ist afrika tätige person
ein vorrat macht so der muttertags
geschenk eine wunderbare vorlage
die arbeit schritt mit der in zusammen
erarbeitet buche langen abend das genau
ab logische schritt für schritt und
schaffe und meinen sie wirklich ihre
motorischen fähigkeiten sind so verkehrt
wird ja dass das was muss einfach
trainer nach und in den endlichkeit hat
mit dem modell manchmal tritt mit bruch
dar
nein er feststellt kind mehrere das
extra um ist serie um ist hinter groß
event macht übernahm sie das signal für
unsere auch sie denn niedriger delta es
also und susanne aus kindergarten fehler
vielen dank für die entwicklung und da
muss man wirklich aufpassen und das ist
doch auch wirklich das sagen dass ich
alles redet über jetzt die bündner
bauskandal zum beispiel das doch nichts
gegen die rinder verschwörung
stattfindet was jahrelang eine
wissenschaftlich überprüfen und und und
antwort es ist im stil der hildegard es
fertig aus dem fenster bürgerkrieg
hinter und nie dabei
nein sie treffen sich als jene gruppe
sie treffen sich im sattel von turnhalle
mit zigaretten und bücherfans die
panini-bilder und entsprechend sie sich
absolut wer zum beispiel hat nur super
heroes und dann wartet dieser alle
kollektiv in drei kinder ja dass sie
heikel und delta das zdf unter der nase
und natürlich der kindergarten war es in
dem urteil
das mache die extra verstösst bist du
hinter
schwierig so das kind hätte nicht zu der
herbe grüne meine kinder an die macht
der drei anbieter bitten das war diese
ganz zivilisation glaubte unter presse
erster oder es gibt dafür schwierig so
das erwachsene kind sind böse
whistleblower bitte glaube ich mehr und
trinken beobachtete das ist ja wie
wiederholte finde immer wieder entdecken
wieder abgerissen verschlimmert die war
die gruppe mehrere briefkästen grad
hitze morgen sind auch im juni dürfte es
damit klappt sie vor unbekannt sind und
wenn ich dann noch de ruft rezepte
verschwinde
und das habe ich vor stattfinden wird in
zentral west verschwinde der heime liebe
eltern können ihrem kind nur gm ist in
die augen
ja meine frage du weißt du ob die so der
tagelangen isst und trinkt zeit nein
nein ich weiß nicht woher gelernt ich
glaube denn nicht sie würde zu ali und
zur mich bitte am besten die sandkasten
grabe tier um wo der kindergarten etwa
den mini überreste finden
sieben jahre ihres lebens verbrachte sie
in einem holz verließ nackt im dunkeln
allein
man nannte sie später auch das mädchen
aus der kiste die entführte collien star
bloß eine stunde am tag ließ er sie raus
und sie zu quälen
der monster peiniger cameron hocker was
treibt einen menschen zu solchen
gräueltaten was spielt sich ab in einem
sadisten gehirn welche narzissmus wucher
da in einem kopf wenn einer ein mädchen
einsperrt um es zu seinem eigentum zu
machen
was treibt einen serienmörder dazu die
leichenteile seiner opfer zu verspeisen
und warum verspürt ein vater das
bedürfnis seine tochter während jahren
ein zu bunkern und zu schenken
auskunft könnten die täter geben doch
die schweigen meist somit bleibt für die
ermittler nur ein weg sie müssen den
tatort ergründen die spuren sichern und
so minutiös jedem detail nachgehen um
den fall aufzuklären
basierend auf einer ausgeklügelten
zusammenarbeit zwischen
kriminalpolizisten forensikern und
rechtsmedizinern können viele
rätselhafte fälle gelöst werden so auch
der erschütternde fall des
vierfachmordes von rapperswil der die
ganze schweiz bewegte wie kaum ein fall
der jüngsten geschichte
die täterschaft konnte nicht zuletzt
dank der auswertung der handydaten
eingegrenzt werden
gut möglich dass thomas n am schluss
auch wegen seiner hundeliebe überführt
wurde
wie verschiedene quellen berichten
wurden am tatort auch dna-spuren seine
huskys gefunden
ja bei mir sitzt jetzt jemand den alle
haben wollen wenn das böse zu schlägt
thomas müller ist kriminalpsychologe und
tatort analytiker erlernte beim fbi und
war bei der ermittlung zahlreicher
serienmörder und schwere verbrechen
beteiligt etwa bei jack unterweger im
fall natascha kampusch bei bei josef
fritzl
bei den deutschen serienmördern horst
david und frank gust aber auch beim
ischer ebene in der schweiz herzlich
willkommen herr müller grüße sie herr
präsident sie untersuchen tatorte
ermitteln den tathergang und schließen
dann aufgrund der verhaltensmuster auf
das profil auf den täter aber ich musste
ich mir das konkret vorstellen
na ja das prinzip dass er einfach was
jeder von ihnen hielt diesmal auch
gleich ausprobieren kann
sie müssen davon ausgehen dass alle
entscheidungen die wir treffen die
brille die wir tragen die schule team
das auto was mir fahren oder so wie wir
uns das wohnzimmer einrichten
im prinzip eine handlung ist um unsere
persönlichkeit darzustellen ist ein
schönes zitat von sigmund freud weil
unsere verhaltensweisen nicht
willkürlich sind sondern auf ein
bestimmtes persönliches bedürfnis zurück
es gibt aber soviel bedürfnisse wie es
menschen gibt die schönsten spieler ist
da das sind 120 leute aber sie sehen
keine 2
die gleichen schuhe anhaben und die
gleiche brillenfassung oder den gleichen
kugel steckt empörung weil wir agieren
weil wir bestimmte bedürfnisse haben und
wenn sie jetzt eine strafbare handlung
begehen agierten sie auch noch ihren
bedürfnissen und das ist individuell wir
suchen also über die entscheidungen am
tatort die persönlichen bedürfnisse zu
kümmern
händler die auf die persönlichkeiten
schlägen aber wie sehen sie ist konkret
ob das irgendwo part gewesen ist ein
sexueller sadist oder ein effekt werde
zum beispiel nun ich sehe nicht wirklich
sympathisch mit dem psychiatrischen
begriffen kommen wir nicht weiter so mit
ihr vorstellen sie sind sachbearbeiter
sie haben ein komplex ist direkt zu
bearbeiten und ich würde ihnen sagen sie
suchen paten wie schatten der aus bei
einer fahrzeugkontrolle das sehen sie
nicht sondern wir müssen versuchen über
die verhaltensweisen ermittlungsansätze
du cap und daher stellt sich die frage
wie kann man verhalten über messen wir
können die kubatur in den arm messen den
sauerstoffgehalt ich kann die größe
messen aber wie messen sie zb gefährlich
loyalität oder residenz und das ist
etwas wie sie hier in der
geisteswissenschaft machen indem wir
messen wenn wir keinen meter maß haben
sondern wir messen indem wir vergleichen
das verhalten einer person und tag und
vergleichen es mit vielen anderen fällen
und deswegen und dass ich vielleicht als
außergewöhnlichen der kriminalpsychologe
brauchen wir diese erkenntnisse von
jenen die gleiche oder ähnliche
verbrechen begangen haben und deswegen
sucht man sich in den gefangenen häusern
auf und lassen und bestimmte
verhaltensweisen erklären
deswegen haben sie auch mit sehr vielen
schwerverbrechern gesprochen darüber
reden wir gleich jetzt interessiert mich
sie sagen täter lügen tatorte aber lügen
nicht deswegen interessiert sie der
tatort wie muss ich das verstehen
wenn jeder von uns das recht zu lügen
oder die unwahrheit zu sagen
etwas schön dort zu stellen dass es
eigentlich ist wer macht das nächst ja
aber es gibt einen augenblick von den
menschen nicht glücklich dann wenn eine
entscheidung trifft die für ihn wichtig
ist ich habe jetzt nur in diesem raum
sagen wenn sie wissen wollen welche
persönlichkeit sie haben schauen sie in
einer eigenen kühlschrank immer da sagte
dann sehr sehr viel über ihre
persönlichkeit über ihre bedürfnisse
seien da nur salat platten oder körben
drin
oder sind die tomaten eier schwimmen
gezählt oder sonstig alte dann kann ich
doch auch inszenieren jetzt aus täter
kann bestimmte spuren hinterlassen
können sie versuchen aber wenn sie
versuchen das motiv einer strafbaren
handlung zu ändern oder zu inszenieren
wie sie sagen
beginnen sie in den meisten fällen einen
fehler weil sie glauben dass der tatort
so aussieht dass nicht auch ein bumerang
der videos sie zurück kommt wenn man
also feststellen dass am tatort
inszeniert ist kann man davon ausgehen
dass es sehr schnell kreditvermittlungen
die kämen jetzt haben sie unzählige
tatorte gesehen und immer die spuren des
bösen das was überbleibt nachdem die
grausame tat passiert ist das sehen sie
gewöhnt man sich daran und wie grenzen
sie sich ab wissen sie mit dem begriff
des bösen können wir in der
kriminalpsychologe nicht agieren das
bringt uns nämlich nichts wir bezeichnen
das als professionelle distanz und ich
habe mich sehr mit hohem interesse jetzt
in ausführungen meiner vorredner und
vorredner zugehört denn das
kriminologische sie müssen sich
vorstellen dass dieses dieses kontinuum
einfach irgendwo wachs es gibt ja kein
zweig an vier kein sex oder kein acht
böse das ist eine wartungs frage und
daher hilft uns eigentlich in der
kriminalpsychologe wir agieren er mit
der terminologie dass wir sagen das ist
ein
fallen er wird deswegen komplex wenn wir
keinen vergleichswert ja wenn sie also
ein verhalten haben wo sie nicht darauf
zurückgreifen können dass ich einmal
erklärt warum man das verhalten setzen
das ist schon sehr komplex und es gibt
verhaltens bereiche die wir immer und
immer und immer wieder sehen sowohl bei
persönlichen tötungsdelikten dass die
täter ihre opfer zu decken teile des
körpers oder das ganze gesicht oder nur
dass die verletzungen
dann haben wir hunderte und tausende
verbindung kann das relativ rasch
interpretieren
jetzt haben sie wirklich mit vielen
krassen fällen gesprochen mit
serientätern sogar beispiel ich habe die
namen aufgezählt aus der distanz würden
sie sagen was überrascht sie da in
diesen gesprächen dass diese menschen
ähnlicher sind als wir glauben
zu uns oder dass sie doch sehr
verschieden sind naja wenn sie
eigentlich john steinbeck für große
literatur nobelpreisträger thomas es
gibt menschen die in erfahrungswelten
leben die wir nicht betreten können
das müsst ihr euch vorstellen wenn die
da oben schritt gehören und sagen herr
müller wie groß ist die person die da
oben geht gerade sagen das weiß ich
nicht ich kann sie nicht messen wer sich
in einer anderen ebene
und wir versuchen in der
kriminalpsychologe doch auf diese ebene
zu gehen indem wir von diesen tätern und
das dürfen sich jetzt nicht falsch
verstehen lernen
die interpretation von verhalten und
wenn mir eine interpretation sagen ich
konnte es glauben oder nicht
aber stellen sie sich vor sie finden in
ganz europa in sieben verschiedenen
strafanstalten oder maßregelvollzug soll
starten
sieben verschiedene leute hinter das
gleiche verhalten setzen und diese
gleich interpretieren können sie bei
machtvoll selber interpretationen geben
ohne dass es etwas braucht haben von
welchem schwerverbrecher haben sie am
meisten gelernt
wer hat sie am stärksten beeindruckt
vielleicht auch also wurde beeindruckt
und glas noch einmal das haben wir nicht
aber sie haben gerade ein foto von
jeffrey dahmer jetzt sagen sie nicht
wenn pro presse hat im ehemaligen leiter
der falten social science vom fbi
interviewt hat und der mann hat die
manipulieren die stimme gehabt die ich
jemals gehört habe und denke ich mit uns
im bereich vorgedrungen wo wir
eigentlich gar nicht mehr hinwollten da
der hat sie manipuliert na ja er hat
sehr hart die stimme dir gehabt das war
so manipulieren dass ich mir
das gespräch es gedacht hat wenn sie
nicht wissen was eigentlich die fantasie
umsetzung dieses mannes ist ahnen sie
nicht was eigentlich dahinter steht
warum haben diese menschen ehrlich seine
lebhafte fantasie wissen sie jeder von
uns hat die fantasie und die frage ist
in welche richtung sie geht freund der
fantasie und regelt die dunkelheit und
die fantasie ist eigentlich etwas sehr
sehr positives denken sie zum beispiel
an den umstand wenn kinder malträtiert
sexuell missbraucht oder sonst irgend
etwas werden richtet die mutter natur
die fantasieren und in dieser fantasie
können sie auch dramatisch überleben
weil sie in der fantasie plötzlich
mächtig sind weil sie sich einbilden
dass sie freunde in form von monster und
oder sonst irgendetwas haben und wenn
das passiert in sehr frühe kindheit das
gewaltfantasien entstehen und die mutter
natur schiebt dann im alter von 10 12 14
jahre tendenz ihn kennt sexualhormone
über diese menschen drüber dann
verbinden sich gewaltfantasien mit der
sexualität und sie haben die basis für
sexualverbrechen
also es gibt nichts im leben was nur
positiv oder negativ ist und so wie der
kollege ist da vielleicht zu viel gesagt
hat es ist die frage in welche richtung
sich aber es gibt keinen menschen der
nur eine seite hat das ist ein duales
system wie viele von denen fühlten sich
schuldig also ich habe keinen einzigen
getroffen
warum fehlt die reue ich will nicht
sagen dass die reihe verhält sondern
über das was er sich am meisten ärgern
ist dass sie irgendwann fehler gemacht
aber da fängt es genau an für um sich
nicht entscheidend was jemand sagt
sondern das was er tut
und deswegen haben wir in der
kriminalpsychologe im vorteil wir müssen
uns sind analysen lassen weil dato zeigt
in der regel das darunter liegende
motivieren kann jemand sehr lange etwas
erzählen ja
aber im endeffekt ist doch die
entscheidung die er getroffen hat bei
der durchführung des verbrechens sagt
situativ in diesem moment in diesem
moment ist das motiv war
wenn sie psychologisch tief bohren was
würden sie sagen in welchem gefühl
wurzelt sage nochmal das böse oder die
schlimme tat in der suche nach der
eigenen wertschätzung und auf der
anderen seite immer angst dass sind die
zwei mächtigsten an träumst und fehlende
fairness welt gesucht ständig die eigene
wertvorstellungen nach oben zu treiben
mich an jedem einzelnen die empfehlung
geben fühlen sie sich nicht so wichtig
nehmen sie sich selbst aus der bedeutung
und es fällt ihnen vieles viel leichter
wann werden sie richtig böse ich weiß
nicht wenn sie mir drei mal die frage
stellen ich hoffe das habe ich nicht
gemacht habe müller vielen herzlichen
dank
sie werden sich gleich nochmal sehen auf
dem sofa ich bitte sie jetzt rüber zu
gehen ab sofort noch mal mit seiner
kollegin barbara bleisch zu diskutieren
das genick der tathergang wie wichtig
ist der eigentlich für sie wenn es darum
geht es nachher zu therapieren genau
also so eine therapie dauert jahre und
ich muss in der tat sagen wir haben sehr
oft von den tätern dass die oft
jahrelang alles tun um sich abzulenken
von ihren taten das heißt viele
therapien werden auch abgebrochen zum
beispiel von tätern durch passive oder
aktive verweigerung weil die merken das
daran zu gehen sehr sehr unangenehm ist
und die abwehrmechanismen
natürlicherweise nicht an solche themen
anzugehen und sich nicht realistisch
plötzlich betrachten so müssen die sind
relativ groß
auf jeden fall die täter die aber
wirklich die therapie durchziehen weil
sie irgendwann an den punkt kommt wo sie
erkennen dass es auch für sie ein
vorteil ist für die zukünftige prognose
vielleicht auch dass sie nicht mehr
immer weiter vor sich selber erkennen
könnten viele beschreiben das als ein
jahrelang habe ich mich zugedröhnt mit
drogen oder mit aktivitäten oder mit
sonst irgendwas weil ich von mir weg
gerannt bin sagen die dann in einem
späteren therapieverlauf und wenn wir
dann immer therapie prozess sind kommen
irgendwann einen punkt der
tatrekonstruktion wo die gefühle
gedanken und verhaltensweisen wirklich
ganz detailliert auseinander genommen
werden
da sind diejenigen aber schon relativ
weit im therapie prozesswissen ihre
muster wissen vielleicht auch wenn sie
diagnosen haben und lernen dann rational
realistisch drauf zu schauen dann sagen
sie nicht mehr es ist mir passiert was
viele täter sagen sondern ich habe es
getan oder nicht war ich konnte gar
nicht anders sondern okay ich habe mich
an dem tag entschieden jetzt die drogen
zu nehmen weil ich mich noch mal
irgendwie pushen wollte und so weiter da
geht jetzt quasi darum die man in der
therapie lernt sich mit den tathergang
auseinanderzusetzen ist noch was anderes
aufgefallen in der art und weise jetzt
der herr müller erzählt hat wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden habe gibt es auch
ebenso typologien die sich wiederholen
deswegen können wir lernen von fällen
aber deswegen würde mich auch
interessieren wenn sie tathergänge
studieren inwiefern sind die wichtig um
nachher der person helfen zu können weil
sie sehen okay wenn man so und so
strukturiert ist dann begeht man das
verbrechen er so und so und so wisse
dass diese typologien nun das ist ein
spannender punkt das wäre auch in der
bundesrepublik untersucht haben weil wir
erkannt haben dass kolleginnen und
kollegen die eigentlichen der therapie
in der maßregelvollzugs anstalt arbeiten
in der regel drei informationsquellen
haben
das ist die urteilsausfertigung das
gutachten konferenz ist piraten in der
hauptverhandlung und den täter selber
und aus diesen drei informationsquellen
können sie kaum bis überhaupt nicht die
dynamik des abrechnungs erkennen sie
wissen eigentlich nicht was das
eigentliche motiv ist und so haben wir
in der größten maßregelvollzugs anstalt
in europa
die ist in reichenborn zunächst damit
begonnen ungefähr 200 leute drinnen
auszubilden die daten lesen zu können
und die eigentliche tat begehren zu
analysieren um dann erst mit den leuten
zu sprechen um zu erkennen was das
darunter liegende motiv frage also der
tatort ist unglaublich wichtig um zu
verstehen was genau passiert ist und die
persönlichkeit auch zu verstehen spricht
den mörder zu finden
weniger die persönlichkeit sondern
situativ was sich zu diesem zeitpunkt an
diesem ort abgespielt hat und was das
darunter liegende bedürfnis waren was
wenn er mir sehr sehr häufig erkannt
dass die täter aufgrund der
fragestellungen mehr in erfahrung
bringen was der fragen ich weiß als dass
wir sie hergeben müssen
und die täter sind nicht daran
interessiert zu sagen was sie eigentlich
tatsächlich dazu getrieben hat und daher
fürchten sie auch irgendwie denn die
information des tatortes weil der mehr
oder minder das wiedergibt oder sigmund
freud verschenkt sagt unsere
persönlichkeit bringt uns jeden tag also
an buchen
da muss ich aber recht widersprechen
weil wir total bemerken dass
persönlichkeits auffälligkeiten auch in
den statistiken auf diese bezug nehmen
doch sich wiederholen und sich auch in
den tatorten wieder spielen das eine hat
hängt ja mit dem anderen auch zusammen
die motive allen ja auch mit den
persönlichkeits konstruktionen zusammen
außerdem ich weiß nicht genau wie das
hier ist wir haben ermittlungsakten also
gerade in der im gefängnis bei der
therapie ermittlungsakten wo auch
tatsächlich tatort bilder und ähnliches
drin sind das heißt diese information
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie das in anderen
ländern ist ich keine ahnung aber mir
ist das so bekannt dass man durchaus die
ermittlungsakten dann auch einsehen kann
und das natürlich auch die gutachten zum
tatverlauf und so weiter berücksichtigt
werden
fakten die wir vorliegen haben also ich
kenne das anders als das jetzt herr
müller sagt vielleicht liegt's an das
doch irgendwie bei uns dann anders läuft
als in österreich keine ahnung aber
jedenfalls muss ich sagen dass wir das
schon als gesamtkonstrukt so sehen und
natürlich ähnliche persönlichkeit
auffälligkeiten auch ähnliche
aktivitäten teilweise auch an tatorten
bedingen würde ich jetzt zumindest sagen
aber gut vielleicht endlich
hundertprozentig einer meinung macht ja
auch nichts denn ich habe das
endresultat und herr müller ist der
ermittler also logischerweise haben wir
sicherlich auch andere schwerpunkte in
der betrachtung und auch im einsatz der
statistiken auf die wir zurückgreifen
das natürlich ganz klar ich würde gern
noch einen anderen punkt aufnehmen bevor
sie sich jetzt in einem binnen diskurs
ich will nämlich gerne den herrn noch
vor weil sie vorhin auch so genickt
haben als der herr müller erzählt hat
von der fantasie des täters und sie
haben das ja auch geschrieben dass sie
gesagt haben das böse und die fantasie
das hat irgendwie eine ganz enge
verbindung vielleicht können sie dazu
noch mal mehr sagen weil man
grundsätzlich immer denkt zum beispiel
wenn wir noch einmal an den comedian
vorhin denken ein fantasievolles kind
ist doch eigentlich was schönes es wird
eine sache des grades und des ausmaßes
ne fantasien an sich sind ja durchaus
positiv ich kann sie haben auch eine
psychologische funktion die sind von ist
haben wir auch gehört
es ist immer eine frage des maßes und
irgendwann können fantasien so stark
sein dass man nicht mehr auskommt die
fantasien geben geben uns gründe für
unser handeln sie schützen und selbst
vor der welt wenn wir uns zu schwach
fühlen wenn wir nicht genug
selbstbewusstsein haben wenn wir
ängstlich sind dann geben uns unsere
fantasien das was wir eigentlich
vermissen in der welt und dann wird es
gefährlich auf diesen punkt weil dann
werden wir radikalisiert in dieser
fantasie und die wirkliche welt ist
nicht mehr die wirkliche welt sondern
eine gefahr eine bedrohung die uns etwas
anhaben möchte viel auf die wir dann
wiederum gewaltsam reagieren und
wünschten und da gab es einen detail was
mir so gefallen hat
daher bilde dass er gesagt hat wenn sie
nicht böse werden wollen wenn ich jetzt
trotzdem mal diesen begriff leben darf
den sie nicht mögen dann hören sie auf
sich so wichtig zu nehmen das ist
eigentlich das schlüssel wir sollten
aufhören und so wichtig zu nehmen und
uns so viel bedeutung zu geben ist
vielleicht die fantasiewelt der versuch
mit dieser beleidigung umzugehen dass
wir
furchtbar unbedeutend sind ich finde ich
habe nichts dagegen dass man etwas
besonderes sein möchte dagegen spricht
aus meiner sicht nichts das ist nicht
per se jetzt böse oder negativ sind die
frage ist immer wie wir unsere bedeutung
unsere persönlichkeit einbringen in die
welt wir können das auf zwei
verschiedene weisen machen einmal auf
kosten der anderen menschen auf kosten
der welt oder so dass die welt auch was
davon hat dass wir win win situationen
erzeugen und dann ist allen gedient und
deswegen würde ich mich per sie gegen
diese dieses bedürfnis etwas zu bedeuten
das bedeutet dass zu machen
argumentieren wenn man das richtig
einsetzen ist das wunderbar für die welt
wollten sie doch mal sagen ich bin kein
philosoph es hat ihn griechenland als
die sieben weiß ich gegeben hatte gesagt
er weiß dass das hat den devices noch
mal gesagt habe ich ein sehr großer satz
und er sagt alles von nichts zu viel mit
anderen worten jeder von uns ist doch
narzisstischer will sich irgendwie
erhöhen durch eine handlung eine gute
sendung machen andere wird ein gutes
buch schreiben der dritte geht
regelmäßig trainieren das ist ein
dilemma aber wenn nicht ein mensch in
der lage sich selbst durch
entscheidungen zu hören sondern indem
man das gleich erreicht indem andere
erniedrigt und niederdrückt dann
sprichst die forensische psychiatrie von
maliki den narzissten von bösartigen
narzissen und dann wird es natürlich
gefährlich ihr buch heißt ja beste
mensch und der titel lässt dann ja erst
einmal zusammen zucken wer ist denn die
beste mensch ich würde sagen jeder von
uns denn da bin ich eigentlich hoffe ich
zumindest in guter gesellschaft es war
immer in der wolfgang goethe und dabei
haben uns schon gesagt ja es gibt keinen
menschen der nicht unter den widrigsten
umständen an anderen umbringen kann
das unterschreibe ich gehe sogar schritt
weiter ich sagt derjenige der noch nie
darüber nachgedacht hat dann andere
umzubringen
der ist mir suspekt aber jetzt kommt das
große aber von blitzenden gedanken des
hasses die überlegung ist vielleicht
wirklich zu tun
so planen den vorbereitungen bis zur tat
ausübung ist ein ewig langer weg und da
hängt jetzt davon ab was habe ich im
laufe der zeit mitbekommen hat mir mein
vater gesagt du musst die sprache
verwenden um den diskurs irgendwie
auszudiskutieren oder drückte mir ein
taschenmesser in der hand und sagt wer
also das sind die einfachen beispiele
die zuhauf dann das ergeben dass ich
sage ich bin in der schwierigen
situation wo ich gekränkt wer woher die
gedemütigt wer trotzdem in der lage mich
nicht so wichtig zu nehmen und zu sagen
okay okay oder ich sagt man jetzt bin
ich gekränkt und kränkungen mache ja
bekanntlicherweise krank wird gern noch
einen anderen schritt machen nämlich zu
einem thema kommen über das wir ja am
anfang schon gesprochen haben sie die
die milram experimente oder die anderen
standort riesen exzellente erwählt haben
nämlich dass sozial böse oder das
organisierte böse und darauf zu sprechen
kommen das ist ja auch das organisierte
verbrechen gibt oder die kollektive tat
denke ein genozid denken jan
terroristische anschläge denken wir auch
natürlich an den holocaust und da würde
ich gerne von ihnen wissen hat das böse
hier ganz andere ursachen aus bei einer
individuellen ich würde sagen es hat
genau dieselben ursachen
es ist wieder eine fantasie eine
scheinwelt die jetzt aber nicht mehr von
einem individuum gelebt oder konstruiert
wird sondern von einem kollektiv durch
eine ideologie
also wir müssen privat fantasien von
ideologien unterscheiden aber im
wesentlichen sind sie doch dasselbe
insofern eben dann in einer ideologie
sich verschiedene menschen
zusammenfinden und gemeinsam
radikalisieren nicht mehr allein
und das kann doch einen viel stärkeren
effekt haben als wenn man nur alleine
ist und sich in seiner privat fantasie
vatikans es gibt da verschiedene
wechselwirkungen die sich gegenseitig
hoch treiben und das nach ideologien und
fanatismus zu gefährlich jetzt gibt es
den begriff der banalität des bösen von
hannah arendt der natürlich da sofort
ein
den sinn kommt und hannah arendt betont
ja das eigentliche drama des eichmanns
in diesem prozess ist eigentlich dass es
ein schreibtischtäter ist ja also es
gibt ja verschiedene möglichkeiten wie
menschen sich selbst rechtfertigen und
viele menschen haben ja auch im zweiten
weltkrieg das wird sehr lang und breit
aufgearbeitet gesagt ich hab ja nur
befehle ausgeführt die anderen haben
auch mitgemacht
daraus hat dann zum beispiel der philip
zimbardo den lucifer effekt auch wenn er
durchaus bis heute diskutiert wird ob
man das so vereinfacht zusammenfassen
kann oder den konzipiert und hat gesagt
wenn man halt die anderen in die
sündenböcke und sich selbst in die guten
ein teil schwarz weiß denken wenn man
sagt die anderen bedrohen durch ihre
eigenschaften oder durch ihre absichten
die man ihnen unterstellt und sich dann
sagt sozusagen wir tun das gute wir
verteidigen uns nur und wenn dann eine
unsicherheit des zweiten weltkriegs
situation sagen wir mal
massenvergewaltigung im krieg ja und sie
sehen dann also lade nachdem sie es
schon sehr sehr viel krasses erlebt
haben das halt ihre leute jetzt ihren
befehlshaber sagt so wir werden jetzt
hier dieses dorf bildern und eine
massenvergewaltigung machen selbst wenn
sie nicht persönlichkeit gestört sind
werden sie natürlich wenn sie
verunsichert sind erstens sagen wo ich
kann mich nicht der autorität
widersetzen oder beziehungsweise ist
erfordert viel mut sich zu widersetzen
es gab immer wieder menschen die das
geschafft haben da brauchen sie aber
sehr sehr viel integrität sehr sehr viel
persönliche stärke um sich auch ein
eigenes risiko sozusagen zu begeben und
zu sagen nein ich mache nicht mit und
die verunsicherung wird durch vergleiche
mit anderen relativiert wenn die anderen
in meiner gruppe das tun dann wird es
richtig sein also muss ja meine
unsicherheit falsch sein dass uns ein
paar damit landet man die philipp zum
bade beschrieben hat wenn sie
zusammenkommen erhöht das stück für
stück die wahrscheinlichkeit dass die
menschen in der gruppe sich ihrer gruppe
nicht widersetzen werden
aber ist das nicht was anderes quasi im
konformismus mitschwimmen sich nicht
widersetzen wollen nicht auf luxen
wollen wer sich selber zu wichtig nehmen
in einer eigenen fantasie zu leben
und schlussendlich eben gegen alles
mitgefühl die tat alleine verbringen ist
das nicht ein großer unterschied
ich denke wir müssen mit dem begriff der
banalität des bösen ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein
weil ich sagen würde das böse ist nie
banal das kann damit nicht gemeint sein
das wäre zynisch zu sagen das böse ist
es wurde hannah arendt ja auch folge
hoffen das ist nicht lustig machen dass
ich denke nicht dass es lustig machen
wollte aber es ist ein bisschen
problematischer begriff und ich denke
wir können so sind daraus gewinnen wenn
wir sagen das böse ist nicht vermessen
das böse gibt sich den anschein der
banalität also schreibtischtäter sind
nicht banal sondern sie rechtfertigen
ihre handlungen in dem sie sagen ich bin
ja nur ein kleines rädchen im getriebe
so kann man die schuld delegieren das
heißt aber nicht dass man schuldlos wäre
sondern darin besteht gerade die
schulter sieht als unschuldig zimmer die
nieren herr müller sie blicken sehr
nachdenklich gibt es für ist visieren
kategorialen unterschied haben nichts
für diana entsprechen aber ich glaube
was sie damit gemeint hat ist folgendes
wenn ich ihnen jetzt die frage stellen
wer hat in diesem raum noch nie in
seinem leben ein gesetz gebrochen
böse ausgerufen oder jemand anderen
etwas böses gewünscht also jetzt die
hand heben dann glaube ich ist niemand
in der lage die anzuheben und das hat er
damit gemeint das ist die banalität der
normalität die normalität des bösen das
ich verkleidet ich habe in meinen
büchern einen satz geschrieben ich
glaube die beste tarnung von menschen
die hochkomplexe und strafbare
handlungen begehen jetzt können sie
meinetwegen das böse einführen ist die
arroganz und überheblichkeit von jenen
die glauben erkennen zu können wie
jemand aussieht der etwas destruktives
auch das ist vielleicht etwas was der
kollege brust hat gefragt was am meisten
erstaunt die menschen die ich interviewt
habe die moses idole der in zehn monaten
42 menschen umgebracht
die andere aus wie sie und ich habe in
kassel einen menschen interviewt er
immerhin 19 kilo von seinem einzigen
freund und seine freunde aufgegessen hat
das ist ein höflicher zuvorkommender
sehr intelligenter mann zu dem wir die
sagen sie ich muss jetzt da gerade zur
sendung haben schweizer fernsehen denke
dass meine kleine kinder aufpassen und
der wird macht das ist die banalität des
bösen von der banalität des bösen machen
jetzt einen sprung zum gehörnten es gibt
ein sprichwort sagt wenn der böse
schläft dann wiegt ihn der teufel und
ich würde vorschlagen die machen mal ein
besuch beim teufel
er mag stinken feuerstein und hörner
tragen oder ganz elegant daherkommen
sicher aber ist der abgrundtief böse der
verwandlungskünstler besitzen tausend
namen und erscheint noch immer sein
unwesen zu treiben
wie kam der teufel in die welt und wie
kommt er wieder raus
zuerst trat er als gefallener engel auch
als kleiner gegenspieler des großen
gottes der war im alten testament noch
erhaben über gut und böse
der philosoph kurt flasch hat sich die
figur des teufels vorgeknöpft
sein befund ihr moralischer der liebe
gott desto böser der teufel
[Musik]
im neuen testament begann er in die
körper der menschen einzudringen
der satan befehligte balls sein eigenes
heer von dämonen der formate martin
luther rang heftig mit ihm und besiegte
ihn trotzdem nicht und so tobt der
teufel durch mittelalter und neuzeit und
mit ihm die hexen angestiftet vom
leibhaftigen persönlich nach der
reformation erreichte die verfolgung von
hexen in katholischen protestantischen
gebieten neue höhepunkte
[Applaus]
mit der aufklärung begann man den teufel
aus dem christentum heraus zu operieren
die aufgeklärte theologie degradierte
ihn zum symbol zur metapher für das
schlechte dieser welt sie betonte den
allmächtigen guten gott drängte den
teufel ins reich der fantasie und ins
unterbewusste die einen stellen ihn in
die sekten ecke für andere ist einfach
krank wer ihn anruft oder sich vor ihm
fürchtet
doch irgendwie ist der teufel einfach
nicht totzukriegen
der vatikan versteht diesen dingen
keinen spaß merkt euch mit dem teufel
verhandelt man nicht
so wird er weiter ausgetrieben auch in
der schweiz gibt es heute in jeder
diözese einen priester der für
exorzismus zuständig ist
andere bischof die erlaubnis gibt kann
ich auch den großen exorzismus
[Musik]
gewisse freikirchen bieten sogenannte
befreiungs dienste an
bei bedarf befreit zb hayssam ist bert
schultes privathäuser von üblen geistern
und armen seelen zumindest in der
christlichen welt sorgt der teufel
weiterhin für aufregung ist er gar ein
thematisches prinzip kurt flasch bilanz
christentum mit teufel machte angst
heldin kristen glaube ohne teufel
schmeckt fad haben hier sitzt nun jemand
der über jahre als teufels verlierer als
satanist gelebt hat mit allem was
dazugehört teufelspakt schwarze magie
flüche und rituale angelo nehrung nennt
er sich passend zur farbe schwarz
herzlich willkommen ernährung da glauben
sie denn heute noch an den teufel also
in meinem weltbild gibt es einen gott
einen lieben gott
und es gibt den teufel und wie zeigt
sich oder wo zeigt sich der teufel wenn
sie heute in die welt hinaus blicken
für mich ist der teufel die figur oder
diese persönlichkeit die den menschen
versucht der teufel schafft versuchungen
oder für den menschen in versuchung aber
die entscheidung dieser versuchung
nachzugeben die liegt bei menschen
selbst gibt es auch böses in dieser welt
wo der teufel seine hand nicht im spiel
hat ich denke wir menschen haben schon
in uns drin die die veranlagung zur
sünde und es braucht wahrscheinlich
nicht sehr viel zu tun eines teufels
damit wir besser werden oder damit wir
böse handeln
das liegt ein stück weit bestimmt in
unserer natur
[Musik]
wir schauen uns jetzt mal kurz an damit
wir das ein bisschen ziemlich greifbar
haben wie er sich eigentlich so lebt als
satanist
alltag auf der fährverbindung meilen
horgen am zürichsee trotz seiner
sozialistischen vergangenheit hat sich
angelo nero zum schiffsführer
hochgearbeitet und teil von mir
obwohl es ist ja bestimmt ob er sich
doch vergangenheit die wurzeln für die
flucht in den satan ismus liegen in der
kindheit die gepflastert ist von unrecht
und ohnmachtsgefühle jahrelang lauern
ihm seine kameraden auf dem schulweg auf
bedrohen und drangsalieren ihn
er kann sich der angriffe nur wehren
indem er sein taschengeld und andere
wertgegenstände hergibt
doch schon die erste ko sind ja weil er
sagt mit der einfacheren ingo zum
einstellung zu springen und das aviva
harry ein schulwechsel beruhigt die
situation doch dann folgt ein weiterer
schicksalsschlag der die christlich
geprägte familie aufs äußerste fordert
anschluss erwachsene schwester erkrankt
an lungenkrebs sowie nichts gelernt auch
nicht geändert hat
das ist also der letzte tropfen
gebraucht hat dass er mich gänzlich vor
allem wohne ich halt früher also klären
von dem ich mich abgewandert haben und
auf seite so nötig jetzt komme graffiti
und richtig
seine entwicklung ist unaufhaltbar
seine umwelt mitsamt seinen christlich
geprägten eltern bringt nicht mehr zu
ihm durch er betritt eine neue welt
schließt den so oft zitierten pakt mit
dem teufel
vor allem pendler vermeintlich harmlose
sache und spart zudem ohne spielgewinn
bewusst dämonen und wo man sich irgendwo
in ein geistiger zustand versetzt wo mir
empfänglich wird für woche führten
allerdings was ich im nachhinein sehr
sehr froh bin ich kann ihnen aber das
tier tötet oder irgendwie metzger bin
ich kann ist riskiert wird boston oder
mandeln oder die augen oder so ich dann
auch für die rituale
die okkulten praktiken bestimmen
zunehmend sein leben er wird zum
sprichwörtlichen zauberlehrling die
geister ruft es zielt das ist maxi ich
will aber im schotter ich will über ein
bis zurück zur wo ich das gefühl korn
hatte mit leichter 2006 der tief und
wendepunkt nero hat einen unbändigen
hass auf seinen besten freund entwickelt
weil der auf die gleiche frau steht
diesen nebenbuhler wähler verfluchen
doch der schuss geht nach hinten los was
ich mir so bewusst wurde was ich da
mache und dass es einfach nur scheiße
was ist da machen dass ich dann
entschlossen das ritual brachen will und
das wahr ist oder unglücklich für die
ist das dann doch roland borer und
das ist genau der punkt sie nicht
möchten dass das ganze negativ obwohl
ich ohne ufer beschworen haben die
negative emotionen oder besser heute wie
man will dass sich das anfang hatte mich
richten
ich habe einfach wie es empfinden
überholt dass sich das so eine
sonderbelastung die schwerpunkte alles
negative sich das ohne verkörpert und
außerdem ich richte ich habe panische
angst und bin dann einfach nur noch
peinlich ist in ordnung sagt rohr
ja eine richtige angst einflößende
geschichte sehr berührend bevor wir
darüber diskutieren wie sie davon
losgekommen sind von diesem teufel
interessiert mich nochmal die
entstehungsgeschichte also im film davor
dieses mobbing in der schule dann der
tod ihrer schwester und krebs sie
fühlten sich von gott verlassen sagen
sie was haben sie sich vom teufel da
erhofft was ich mir vom teufel erhofft
habe das war eigentlich eine möglichkeit
mich zur wehr setzen zu können wie ich
gerade meinen klassenkameraden oder zu
dieser zeit an war ich schon ein
bisschen älter einfach allen personen
die mir schlechtes antaten ich war nicht
groß ich war nicht stark ich konnte mich
physisch schlecht wären
und da suchte ich mir meine hilfe beim
teufel im durch diese rituale damit ich
diese personen die mir böses taten
vermeintlichen zurückzahlen konnte das
heißt es ging es im wesentlichen um
macht und um kontrolle und um rache und
um rache und hat das funktioniert diese
flüche das ist natürlich immer so eine
sache
in meinen augen hat es funktioniert wenn
man das jetzt das ganze objektiv
betrachtet dann stellt sich immer die
fragen sind dass zufälle die sich häufen
oder war jetzt wirklich dieses ritual
der auslagen sich ein beispiel geben
ein beispiel wäre zum beispiel ein
ritual in dem man eine krankheit auf
jemanden schickt das ritual durchgeführt
diese person wird und hauptsächlich in
den nächsten tagen und in den nächsten
wochen erkrankt sie dann sieht man das
schon aus einer bestätigung dafür dass
man sein ziel durch dieses ritual
erreicht haben die möglichkeit dass
diese person aber sowieso erkrankt wäre
besteht natürlich und das ist
interessant die faszination für das böse
die geben ganz weit zurück bis in die
kindheit
sie haben sich da in den geschichten oft
mit den bösen charakteren identifiziert
und dann früh auch angefahren so okkulte
rituale zu machen war das auch neben
dieser kontrolle warnt dass diese macht
fantasie auch neue lust an der eigenen
angst ich nein angst nicht ich hatte
keine angst vor diesem figuren das wort
die faszination für diese figuren
es ist einfach eine böse figuren sei das
in büchern sein dass in filmen überhaupt
in geschichten über eine faszination aus
weil sie einfach tiefgründiger sind als
die guten das ist in meinen augen auch
heute noch ist das eine tatsache böse
charaktere sind interessanter die guten
sind ja auch die sind halt einfach gut
aus einige jetzt reden wir über die
wände sie sind ja heute kein satanist
mehr obwohl sie sich noch so aussehen in
meinen augen sie tragen das beispiel
schwarz diese ringe hier vielleicht
können wir ja mal zeigen warum tragen
sie das ganze zurück nach also zu den
ringen auf diesem ist ein kreuz drauf wo
hier auf diesem bild das hier ist bloß
ein wurf und bei diesem ring im innern
steht gottes ende endet nie also soviel
zu den ringen
ansonsten ich fühle mich in schwarz
einfach wohl aber man hat auch im video
gesehen ich kann auch mit blue jeans
tragen
es ist ja nicht so dass ich mich bloß
schwarz kleinen jetzt erzählen sie noch
mal wir haben dieses ritual gesehen im
wald das der anfang war einer wende da
haben sich das böse gegen sie gewendet
sie kreierten angst gekriegt was ist
dann passiert wie kamen sie los von
diesem teufel genau also dieses ritual
da habe ich gemerkt ich habe nicht ich
habe ich habe nicht die kontrolle die
ich mir eingeredet habe es hat sich
umgekehrt emotional gegen mich gewendet
ich kam an einem punkt an dem ich mich
reflektieren konnte ich habe gemerkt was
was ich hier überhaupt tun dass ich mich
selber über alles andere stellen um ja
nicht selber verherrliche indem ich
indem ich immer das gefühl habe ich mich
recht behalten und müsse mich erreichen
können und
das mit mitteln die die nicht gut waren
also ich habe einen richtigen haus gegen
mich selber entwickelt eine abscheu
gegen mich sein wird
ich komme so weit dass ich am morgen
nicht einmal mehr in den spiegel blicken
konnte ohne dass es mich einmal gewirkt
hätte und es kam sogar so weit zu einem
suizidversuch
so ist es genau das kommt dann so weit
dass ich mich auf einer brücke stellte
und ich von dieser brücke springen
wollte weil ich einfach nicht mehr
ertragen konnte was aus mir geworden ist
ich habe dann gott um hilfe angefleht
und die hilfe kaum jahr in form dieses
telefonanrufs von einem schulfreund aus
auf den ich seit jahren nicht mehr
gesehen oder gesprochen hätte er mich
angerufen hat und einfach gefragt hey du
hättest du lust mit in die ferien zu
kommen
schlussendlich stellt sich heraus das
war nicht einfach bloß ferien sondern
das war ein christliches camp und ich
dachte da noch im ersten moment zogen
pure nein danke aber aber doch ich
wollte er dass etwas passiert und sind
ab dem ganzen eine chance gegen mit in
dieses camp komplett in schwarz langen
schwarzen ledermantel weiß geschminktes
gesicht umgekehrt des crashs klauen
ringe also ich hab die ganze montur auf
gefahren weil ich wollte dass die mich
nicht dabei haben wohnen damit ich
wieder eine ausrede habe auf
irgendjemanden sauer zu sein und gott
die show zu geben dass es wieder mal
nicht gekommen hat aber alles was
passiert ist ich gegen hin zu diesem
treffpunkt und die kamen auf mich zu und
sagten schön dass du da bist und ich
wusste mitgehen und und haben sozusagen
haus durch liebe er sei es ja auch was
sie gemacht haben
ich fand es interessant ist der suizid
versucht dort haben sie die eigene
schwäche entdeckt könnte man sagen oder
wieder entdeckt jetzt heute zwei sachen
siegel haben noch andere versicherer
haben an gott zweifeln sie manchmal
nicht denken sie nicht ich habe ja in
einer fantasiewelt gelebt wie das hören
das sind alles nur hirngespinste es ist
tatsächlich sehr schwierig jetzt gerade
wenn man diese wenn ich diese
empfindungen bei diesem einen ritual
reflektiere
es ist tatsächlich sehr schwierig das
nachzuempfinden was ich damals empfunden
habe wenn ich heute darüber nachdenke
muss ich einräumen
vielleicht habe ich mich doch etwas
reingesteigert vielleicht habe ich mich
das alles nur eingebildet vielleicht
habe ich mich emotional so auf einer
ebene begeben wo diese eindrücke kommen
mussten
und das ist es ist tatsächlich sehr
schwierig das zu differenzieren war das
echt oder war das bloß in meinem kopf
aber ich weiß in diesem moment war es
für mich sehr echt fühlte sich echt
unserer vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch vielen dank
bei uns sitzt jetzt herr burkhard stehe
ich ja auch noch einmal ganz herzlich
begrüße sie waren 25 jahre im gefängnis
haben wir bereits gehört und ich möchte
in dieser letzten runde jetzt noch über
die frage sprechen was ist eigentlich
eine gerechte strafe und mit ihnen
gleich anfangen war diese strafe gerecht
also sie war zumindest gerechtfertigt
wenn wir die frage ist ja was ist
gerecht letztendlich glaube ich dass
strafen nur dann gerecht sein können
wenn sie die menschen in ihr positives
potenzial zurückzuführen versuchen daran
scheitert der strafvollzug sehr oft weil
ja strafvollzug ja zum teil auch
befriedigung des rachebedürfnis ist was
psychologisch durchaus in ordnung ist
was gesellschaftlich aber grenzwertig
ist weil werfen wir einen blick nach
albanien da gibt es ganze dörfer da
gibt's keine männer mehr weil und frauen
verkleidet sich als männer um die
blutrache weiterführen zu können
das passiert wenn man gesellschaftlich
rache als probates mittel anerkennt ich
glaube dass wir letztendlich auf dem
richtigen weg sind
dass wir aber jetzt gerade in
entwicklungs schwierigkeiten stecken und
wir weitergehen müssen darin das
potenzial in jedem menschen zu sehen und
ich finde da hat norwegen uns mit mit
der viking fantastisches beispiel
geliefert wo sich eine gesamte
gesellschaft geweigert hat sich von
einem einzelnen mann neue gesetze
diktieren lassen muss sagt er nein wir
glauben weiter an das gute im menschen
und wir lassen uns das nicht von einem
einzelnen sind stören
das würde auch heißen dass ein täter wie
jener von rupperswil der ja bereits in
einem einspieler vorgekommen ist die
schweiz natürlich waren sie nicht bewegt
hat in den letzten monaten der
verscherzt es sozusagen nicht vor dem
recht
herr nolle ist das so hat jeder mensch
jetzt nicht nur rechtlich gesehen
sondern auch moralisch gesehen das recht
darauf auf eine zweite chance würde ich
unbedingt bejahen und zwar deswegen weil
er eben die freiheit zum guten wie zum
bösen hat also wie schon gesagt wurde
es besteht immer die möglichkeit es muss
die möglichkeit bestehen dass der weg
wieder zurück gefunden wird dass die
eine transformation stattfindet deswegen
bin ich auch der meinung strafe sollte
nicht aus rachegefühlen erfolgen sondern
sollte konstruktiv sein also wie
schaffen wir es den täter zur einsicht
in die realität seine handlung zu
bringen wie schaffen wir es wieder rück
zu binden an die welt von der sich
entfernt hat indem er sich eigene schein
bilden konstruiert hat das heißt die
strafe muss dazu dass sein
diese scheinwelten abzubauen und wieder
zurück zur welt zu finden und das geht
nicht von heute auf morgen dann muss man
ihn natürlich begleiten und das kann
eben durch den freiheitsentzug geschick
gibt es fälle bei denen sie frau
wernicke festgestellt haben hier ist
wirklich nichts zu therapieren
selbstverständlich gibt es de und ich
glaube es gibt auch niemanden in der
fachwelt das ernsthaft abstreiten würde
es gibt tatsächlich diese persönlichkeit
mischungen die mit den jetzigen mitteln
nicht wirklich in den griff zu kriegen
sind es gibt natürlich letzte
möglichkeit manchmal werden dann die
chemischen kastration ein gesetz zum
beispiel aber auch dass es keine
generallösung für alle und oft kommen
sachen zusammen zum beispiel gefährliche
sexuelle tötungsfantasien mit
psychopathie werten die hoch sind wenn
sie so eine mischung haben ich denke
ungefähr das meinten sie herr müller
dann ist da natürlich nicht viel zu
machen
aber es gibt halt viele täter die haben
nicht dieses krasse störungs ausmaß und
da wo das störungs ausmaß nicht dieses
niveau erreicht oder diese kombination
da kann man sicherlich einiges machen
sorry das kann ich nicht ganz so stehen
lassen okay ich habe mit diesen menschen
die sie so bezeichnen zusammengelebt und
alles was sich letztendlich darunter
gesehen habe ist immer schmerz und anja
das und wenn ja wenn wir einen menschen
diesen schmerz ein ventil geben mit
diesem schmerz umzugehen und dann werden
die angst nehmen können dann besteht
auch immer die möglichkeit dass er den
rückweg finde
sie argumentieren sehr stark oder
plädieren dafür jedem eine zweite chance
zu geben
jetzt würde ich aber gerne auch jetzt
sogar noch weiter ich habe meine zweite
chance weggeworfen haben
danach dann erst in gesellschaft
zurückgekehrt und leiste meiner meinung
nach jetzt gesellschaftspolitisch sehr
wichtige arbeit war heutige moderne
therapiemaßnahmen gehen eigentlich immer
darauf hin dass fiel verhalten aus dem
menschen herauszunehmen
aber dabei bleibt immer noch ein loch
und das müssen wir irgendwie müssen wir
für den menschen irgendwie fühlen
damit der mensch als ganzes dastehen
kann und das versuchen wir mit yoga und
meditation zu erreichen nehmen wir den
menschen eine kraftquelle mit in die
therapiemaßnahmen hinein bringen
da wird durchaus ansätze anderen
strategien emotionsregulation wobei sich
das eine mit dem anderen nicht
widerspricht also durchaus
emotionsregulation aufwertungen durch
pro soziale verhaltensweisen eine auch
meinetwegen artistische aufwertung nicht
über straftaten sondern über andere
dinge natürlich haben wir das in unseren
konzepten drinnen deswegen prinzipiell
nur es gibt wirklich viele die so schwer
multiple faktoren zusammen haben dass
der wahrscheinlich gutachten
zweifelsfrei sich überlegen wird da ist
dieses wie hoch ist die gefahr für die
gesellschaft yao ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit da muss man dann im
zweifelsfall wirklich die abwägung
treffen und dann muss der juristisch am
ende das dann ich würde gerne ja gerne
hier kurz unterbrechen und einfach auch
noch mal fragen was ist eine gerechte
strafe und wozu ist strafen nicht da und
es gibt ja einerseits diese idee der
individuelle prävention dass ein täter
eben nicht noch einmal eine tat begeht
die soziale prävention dass wir nicht
eher müller sagt er damit rechnen müssen
dass eine weitere frau vergewaltigt wird
aber es gibt ja schon so was eben auch
wie die idee der gerechtigkeit die söhne
die passieren muss auch das wieder ins
gleichgewicht bringen
und da kommen doch auch die opfer
schlussendlich ins spiel also denken wir
an die hinterbliebenen beispielsweise im
falle von rupperswil die immer wieder
gesagt haben
der täter muss gefasst werden nur dann
kann vielleicht ein kleines kätzchen
ruhe oder seelenfrieden überhaupt erst
einkehren herrn ola gibt es diese idee
nicht auch sicherlich sie sagte aber es
geht uns ins gleichgewicht
kommen und ich glaube man kommt dann ins
gleichgewicht in der täter die moralität
seine handlung einzieht und berührt ich
glaube dass da auch der opferfamilie
schon ein schritt verrät gedient ist
wenn die opferfamilie bemerkt hier
bereut jemand seine tat und zwar ehrlich
das braucht natürlich eine gewisse zeit
es gibt ein neuer ansätze fahren in den
usa wo täter und opfer sich begegnen wo
man versucht diese begegnungsräume zu
schaffen um das auf einer sehr
persönlichen ebene zumindest die beiden
ins gespräch zu bringen wäre das ist das
ein weg der auch diskutiert wird
sicherlich ist das eine möglichkeit ich
stehe dem täter opfer ausgleich aber ein
wenig kritisch gegenüber weil es die
opfer sehr leicht noch mal zu opfern
machen kann wenn eine so große
institution wie die justiz auf ein opfer
zugeht und sagt wir würden sie gerne
dafür gewinnen mit dem täter liegt in
einen dialog einzutreten
dann gehört schon eine ganze menge
rückgrat des opfers dazu zu sagen das
will ich nicht ich von hier aus sollte
der den rest seines lebens mit den füßen
nach unten und nach oben aufgehängt
werden damit er richtig was davon hat
und wenn wir von freiheit reden dann hat
auch das opfer diese freiheit zu haben
diesen wunsch zu hegen wir als
gesellschaft sind die bremse dazwischen
nun zwischen zwischen dem wunsch nach
rache und der ausübung der rache
aber wie ist das wenn ein opfer jetzt in
diese situation gebracht wird und sich
jetzt mit dem thema auseinandersetzen
muss und das sehe ich ein bisschen
kritisch das würden wir auch nicht
unbedingt in jedem fall also sozusagen
wollen es gibt tatsächlich völlig denke
gerade ein sexualstraftaten wo täter und
opfer aus einer familie kommen oder eine
emotionale bindung hat ein schwieriges
thema manche opfer wollen dann die den
cut haben was auch dann verständliches
manche machen mit therapie und von dem
zuge der therapie eine aussprache
begleitet mit der therapeutin oder dem
therapeuten das muss man im einzelfall
dann sehen wir würden so was zum
beispiel nicht empfehlen wenn das opfer
keine therapeutische begleitung hat die
dann auch entscheiden kann ob das jetzt
wirklich hilfreich ist oder nicht es
gibt fälle wo seine aussprache deinem zu
besonder opfer therapie auch gemacht
wird aber ich glaube da gibt es keine 08
15 regel und die freiheit des opfers ist
hier wirklich ganz entscheidend dass die
rauchschaden punkt manemann genau wir
sagen auch immer tätern zum beispiel die
väter waren wenn sie sagen ich möchte
mich bei meiner tochter entschuldigen
und wir sagen wenn ihre tochter
entscheidet nie wieder mit ihm kontakt
aufzunehmen dann werden sie bis zu ihrem
tod keinen kontakt mit ihrer tochter
haben oder ihren sohn und das verlangen
wir von ihnen weil das opfer hat die
entscheidungsfreiheit so und da bin ich
schon auch bei ihrer der täter dem opfer
die freiheit genommen ja die freiheit
der entscheidung ja wie freiheit und das
böse zusammenhängen und wie die strafe
dann auch mit rein kommt darüber ließe
sich noch lange diskutieren ich habe
heute abend festgestellt das böse kommt
nicht nur aus leisen sohlen es
schlummert in allen von uns ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich dass sie hier waren
herr gurkhas frau wenige herr nolle herr
müller vielen herzlichen dank
die alle im saal und natürlich auch an
sie zu hause für interesse am bösen und
jetzt gleich gehts weiter mit zwei bösen
spielfilmen nämlich mit hannibal und
roter drache
falls sie also bereits im sog des bösen
sind dann bleiben sie noch etwas dran
ich sage tschüss und das schlusswort
übergebe ich an den comedian dominik der
wird mehr ins bereichs mehrere stürze
big auto wie es ein extra vater nicht
auch hin sind fasziniert vom bösen gibt
es böse liebe stuft er als pci langweile
geben können das ergebnis beispiel kind
stünde das aufhören und den satz jeder
machen sie lieber der tür für sie lebt
der böse zauberer sie hier mittags oder
gebert weg was böses spiel der darth
vader natürlich auch das absolut böse
gekriegt das absolute böse liebe fc
basel zum zu spät ja wie gott mir damit
um pädagogisch leider sind viele eltern
oder erwachsene dazu neigen dass sie das
versuche jetzt verbauen des bösen lager
vertreters natürlich pädagoge statt auf
ausnahmen wie zum beispiel der
samichlaus kind freut sich zusammen aus
aber was mich vergessen vor ort genauso
auf der schmutzigen der krampus also
böse womit dem samichlaus grund sie
brauchen das event das was macht die
erwachsenen neuerdings sie lernte
krampus also schmutzler erwarten uns
schon oft nur langweilige samichlaus und
trotzdem noch weiter zusammen ist man
also den früheren regen wir die gute und
die schlechte sachen sind seit boes und
kuriert und schaffte das buch erkennt
was man erzählen ältere zusagen
einsammeln moral predigen alter ist ein
unfreiwilliges bilderbücher zell und dem
kanal wieder komplett falsch wir selber
dem die spieler vom sams bücher fürs
kinderhospiz urlaub ich hatte einen
pädagogischen ansatz gewählt und zwar
auf klassisches angeschlossen und in dem
kindergarten mit geübt haben auf den
sauber geschrieben haben das ist ganz
einfach prägnanter für punkt und
bitterbös da ist es noch zum abschied
sagen wir klaus gedicht gott so an
bahngleis siehst du die roth wies
appetit bleibt das land also nicht gut
nacht miteinander
[Applaus]
[Musik]